you're gonna see this phenomenon of men
either dating older women like 10 to 15
years older and they're like well he's
hot enough they might cheat a little bit
but she's hot enough I can you know
reward with being like the good looking
guy and then I can cook and that's way
easier
um and it was funny that I saw this
story so uh boss babe I make more money
than my man so he's the stay-at-home Dad
too many women don't want to work
they're lazy Jalen Cox a 29 year old
mother from Glasgow is the breadwinner
of her family and proud of her role as
the main provider for her two children
she works as an only fan model and
returned to her strip club job shortly
after giving birth